welcome back to the rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of rick and
morty season 5 episode 2
multiplicity a title inspired by the
1996 michael keaton clone comedy
multiplicity with some copy of a copy
gags that don't really age all that well
so god bless rick and morty for
heightening the concept now to body
mutilation
as always there are a ton of easter eggs
callbacks
horny animation details that you might
have missed so i'm gonna break them all
down
the episode opens with this bold
declaration christian god is real he's
been asleep for thousands of years we're
gonna sneak up there and kill him now of
course we never see this happen because
this decoy family gets
killed but by the end of the episode
another rick declares himself god
i'm not a man i'm god
[Music]
you're just made in my image and that
god rick ends up dead so in a way this
episode
kills god while letting the christian
god live on immortal
now they're killed by these squid
assassins later revealed his costumes
worn by
other decoy families so why did some
rick choose squids
well rick speculates later that he might
have banged their queen with his huge
member
and notice here that their heads are
designed to look like huge vaginas
and when rick drops his pants to trick
morty with that fart
the digitally blurred regents suggests
he has got the goods
now the second decoy family hunts mr
always wants to be hunted a greased up
living target that kind of looks like he
could belong to the same race as mr
poopy butthole though jerry later calls
him a starfish person
and we did just see a starfish person
with mr nimmi's last episode but notice
how rick says
don't trust him to completion yeah maybe
rick knows that if this guy's ever
caught or is no longer hunted as we see
later he becomes
murderous or maybe rick needs him for
another purpose i'll get to that later
but jerry surprisingly is the voice of
reason in the car as he follows up on
this dude protect why does he always
want to be hunted jerry's not important
right now dad
why was he in that cryopod yeah had they
all been more wary of mr always wants to
be hunted
rick might have seen him coming at the
end now in italy morty flirts with this
hunk throwing peaches at him as more
peaches hang over head this is a nod to
the 2017 timothy chalamet
army hammer movie and book it was based
on call me by your name
where very sexual things are done with
peaches
and a couple with a very uncomfortable
age gap also look behind them in the
water
there's a little sailboat heading down
the coast i'm wondering if this could be
the same boat that jerry and sleepy gary
hooked up on which is also on the
italian coast
i know that was a false memory but this
whole decoy episode seems to be a
parallel to total rick hall in the way
that it dashes through these
non-canonical memories i like how as
they pack rick's bag is a stupid eye
pizza slice italy shirt and a beth's
suitcase a book
about horses in italy since yeah she's a
horse surgeon and notice how when jerry
gets half vaporized he's left with no
legs and only one arm kind of like
anakin skywalker after
obi-wan had the high ground but before i
continue thanks to vessi for sponsoring
this video
bessie makes these knit sneakers that
are 100 waterproof and snow proof
they're super breathable so they don't
let any liquid in but they let the air
move
out genius inventors like rick sanchez
wish they could design
genius tech this functional this these
shoes are super stretchy they fit like a
sock and they only weigh 175 grams which
is way less than the cheese log i made
for my picnic
you're gonna eat it all and they're made
with this cool dimetex material that
keep your feet warm in cold weather but
cool in warm weather and it's super easy
to clean with just a rinse of water
so if i accidentally dip my toes in the
water my socks stay
nice and dry you know when the weather's
nice i like to lounge by the pool
but sometimes i'm just lounging too much
and plunk
my shoes got all wet but hey wouldn't
you know it next to these messy knit
sneakers my little
piggies are bone dry thanks messi
the pool soup these are truly your
everyday shoe they may not have
like iron man jet propulsors in them but
they do have everything you need in a
non-flying shoe
this is the perfect gift for you and
your loved one especially for the rainy
time of year so get them while they
still have sizes and you can thank me
later
check them out in the link below and use
my code new rockstars to get 25
off your vessy shoes morty and rick
watch wen wolf on
interdimensional cable with a werewolf
who time travels using the same kneeling
time orb pose as the terminator films
which actually one of the time traveling
snakes did in season four
and dracula sells them i'm safe here ian
christianity hasn't been invented yet
crosses are just baby teas to me now
i love it when wolf and dracula go back
to before christianity was invented
whereas wooden jerry advances to a
future where christianity gets
reinvented
and dracula also says i'm out don't
invite me back
in you know because vampire invitation
rules
you got it i'm sure you did for the
second episode in a row rick references
his wife diane
if you really want to know what happened
to beth's mom at this point i don't
think the show will ever really reveal
what happened there just kind of turned
the mystery into a running joke
and beth and rick argue about rick's
past cloning of beth that technically
happened at the end of season three but
then was revisited in the season four
finale
yeah no everyone gets killer
doppelganger's cool deal now spacebeth
who actually might have been the
original beth with this one instead
being the clone we'll never really know
she does appear at the end of this
episode saying not to get too excited
about her return
i think telling us that this whole decoy
episode is the show blowing out the idea
of
in universe clones so that they don't
have to address clone beth again for a
while
so rick finds this decoy family analysis
mode password eight zero zero eight five
yeah eight zero eight five is and
calculator leadspeak
boobs and morty compares his decoy to
westworld damn
like westworld yes morty like westworld
but don't [ __ ] them i've always
referencing the ai hosts of hbo's
westworld who also get frozen with
diagnostic
exams and are built mainly so guests can
sleep with and kill them
actually later the other decoy morty
compares it to x machina which is a 2014
alex garland movie with similar themes
and also an ai that the dude wants to
sleep with actually later when summer
cuts herself to see if she's real that
happens in ex machina and then rick
pulls off the arm skin
just like in t2 judgment day and later
rick says this mission to kill them all
is more termite infestation
than blade runner with of course blade
runner being the ai hunting story that
this whole genre really was inspired by
down in the decoy family's decoy lab
decoy morty's face in the foreground
opens from the center like the little
boy in westworld
and among the equations there is one
with a in front of two
integral symbols looking like the word
ass kind of like the way ass is often
just written on mr goldenfold's
chalkboard
rick's map of other decoys shows one in
baja mexico those could actually be the
ones on that mexican beach later on and
then one near vegas
one near little rock arkansas i think
and then one in either upstate new york
or the great lakes region
and then one off the coast of my
hometown jacksonville florida baby
i hated high school there and you can
see how each point seems to be
geographically
sectioned off from each other part of
rick's design to keep these decoys from
interacting
admittedly this was a bit poorly
conceived even if rick programmed the
decoys to perceive their neighborhoods
as just
normal eventually they would have
crossed paths and started duplicating
when other decoy ricks started
independently creating their own decoys
but i think the idea of this is that
rick only began this decoy program
recently after the clone beth incident
and now we're seeing the natural
consequence of it immediately
snowballing out of control now the next
decoy rick is watching on tv recruiting
soap opera the days and nights of mrs
pancakes you don't know me
and this decoy has a new passcode
analysis mode password 8
equals sign equal sign capital d aka
dick now the decoy families just
immediately jump into a shootout
because as rick explains the prisoner's
dilemma which is a classic game theory
concept in which you can never
really trust a partner to cooperate in
both of your mutual self-interests and
instead
you should just expect the other guy to
screw you over it's the same piece of
game theory that christopher nolan used
with the fairy in the dark knight and
not that it matters but when the two
decoy families rush each other the
family led by the rick who chose the
analysis code
boobs would have defeated the family
with the rick that shows the analysis
code dick
notice how boobs morty stabs and kills
dick morty right away whereas boobs
summer ko's
dick summer so boobs beats dick i i
think i can get behind that but then
both are killed by another family
outside with a lava gun
we actually saw rick with the lava gun
in one of the crystals in the opening
scene of last episode maybe many of
those are moments from the upcoming
season
and rick explains us all as an asimov
cascade referencing
isaac asimov i robot author who coined
the three laws of robotics and
postulated in his fiction that ai's
inevitably turn
on their creators rick's whiteboard
depicts his decoy family tree
stemming from one red circle at the top
with one degree written beside it
meaning this would be the prime rick
rick who first created the decoy program
with the broader tiers outward marks
second degree and third degree
now above that is 008 equals 889 which
doesn't really make mathematical sense
but it could refer to the range of
number of decoys in existence
or as i speculated and explained that a
decoy family that we think is one number
is actually an earlier decoy family as
is the case later when that puppet
disguise family
is the family we saw chasing mr always
wants to be hunted rick cites highlander
the 1986 classic with a similar plot
about
immortal warriors who battle it out
because there can only be one he also
warns about how things get weird when
you make a copy of a copy a nod to
multiplicity when keaton's copy of a
copy gets
well slower i want to buy you a present
for this
a chainsaw but in the case of rick and
morty this line foreshadows how ricks
with lesser and lesser technical skill
make decoys out of things like
scarecrows and
wood baskets pottery and then after
disguising themselves in crappy squid
costumes they realize the actual squids
hunting them are
other decoys meaning this other family
was way ahead of their costume game
and thus makes them decoys just trying
to copy the original
and this leads to a montage set to music
that sounds like nina simone's center
man
a song that scored the heist sequence in
the 1999 thomas crown affair that
featured various duplicate decoys much
like rick and his decoys here that movie
was also mocked in last season's heist
con episode i think the writers are kind
of into
it i love this insane little creature
that poops out candy when it gets
electrocuted and then on the map of the
squid rick who bombs them there is
another rigged decoy located south of
cuba it looks like
then more decoys killing decoys until
another decoy family runs through this
spooky forest notice how they pass these
creepy strung up twig sculptures or
similar to the blair witch
their captor is a scarecrow decoy rick
who now skins
human decoys to make skin suits for
himself and his family similar to
buffalo bill and the texas chainsaw
massacre but also reminding me of that
terrifying herald scarecrow short story
and scary stories to tell in the dark
that haunted me as a kid
and now now the successive skinned rick
decoy victims are less and less
technologically sophisticated from a
cybernetically enhanced organism because
we know rick walks around with implants
like this all the time to this cyborg
skeleton
that's kind of like terminator rules
human tissue on android skeleton
then a steampunky looking robot with a
furnace belly
than to one that that guy would make
made out of barrels and hay and notice
how scarecrow rick stops to the right of
him to make him the end of that line of
succession similar to the framing of the
successive axiom captains in pixar's
wall-e
now rick groans kill me it's now kind of
a running joke here all the time but
originally this is a line from a deleted
scene in the first alien film when
ripley finds her crew being cocooned
alive by the xenomorph
they end up getting saved by this wooden
toy decoy family who speak via
goofy voice boxes though i love that
they kept in rick's chin drool
their flying ship is similarly wooden
with barrels and wooden wheels
and they have this cult refuge the cause
for decoys and they try to defy game
theory by working together but they end
up being a victim to game theory
nonetheless when they get bombed
wooden jerry takes the varnish and he
prevents anyone else's escape to live
his tortuous
mortal existence in the post-credits
scene talk about that later now on the
beach rick says
any place we'd think to hide is a place
they'd think to look it's rule 34 of an
asimov cascade
rule 34 being the internet maxim that
for any conceivable topic
porn exists of it then rick summons all
other decoys with this giant hollow
beacon
calling it a star fox boss season 4
callback
so he's referencing andros from the star
fox games but also with season four
there's two things you can be pulling
from the season four episode one moment
when hollow rick got a physical body and
grew large
or how in season four episode seven
morty complained about having to use a
sword and wanted a laser with which
morty now gets now one of the decoy
families who sees this beacon is a
basket family with that rick
explaining the asimov cascade in the
dirt with a twig another drives through
the southwest
thelma and luis style it looks to be
made out of ceramic pottery and then
keith david returns as the president
this episode with some good thoughts
about the u.s electoral college
how many of those states voted for me
anyway mr president i think the point of
the electoral college is to preserve
slavery that's right steve i have the
internet too
now take your white ass to the
kitchenette and bring me a diet coke
rick
arms beth with a huge blaster summer
with a dual wheeled saber like darth
maul morty with that laser whip and the
jerry with this tiny tiny revolver that
he had in his pocket during the melee
one rick melts another who's carrying a
knife and then himself is shot with
something that makes him explode from
the inside out another family gets
bombed by a squid ship and it turns her
skeletons green kind of like the martian
lasers and mars attacks and then felt
puppet decoy family is revealed to just
be puppet costumes and then they return
to find the last family standing
with that rick now wearing synthetic
entrails of his victims and as these two
families fight notice how one jerry just
drops his revolver while the other drops
his cookware and they just hug
sobbing one summer stabs the other
slowly in the chest like that horrific
scene in saving private ryan and then in
trails rig tries to kill the other by
biting into his suicide pill in his
tooth rick actually revealed these
existed last episode
there are suicide capsules in all of
your teeth do what you want with that
come on morty you're on booze duty jerry
hides in the closet one of the games
behind him is fuggles
make four letter words just like a dumb
baby version of boggle but then they're
all killed by mr always wants to be
hunted
you shoulda hunted me what god i have
so many questions why what happens if
somebody hunt me so one other theory for
this guy he may have just been a safety
protocol by
the prime rick to clean up the
warring decoys if an asimov cascade were
to ever occur
but fortunately all this carnage was
avoided by the family we've been
following up on a space adventure with
space beth returning from the season
four finale and might be the last time
we see her for a while now the
post-credits sequence follows that
runaway wooden jerry who varnishes
himself so that he can float down this
river
only to find himself as part of a beaver
dam unable to die the ultimate
highlander trapped in the cycles of
history
actually the music of queens who wants
to live forever was actually written for
the highlander soundtrack he gets
discovered by a woodpecker and this
dolphin person
which is a subtle callback to the time
cop in season two episode one who's
talking about future dolphin people on
earth no
earth dude i'm talking about yeah with
the dinosaurs
no if you get to the dolphin people
you're going too far jerry later becomes
part of a saloon mirror realizing that
history has cycled back on cowboys but
these are steampunk cowboys and notice
the mechanical arms metallic building
structures outside and then lastly he
becomes part of the wood of the crosses
to crucify the new christ as
christianity is reinvented rick set out
this episode to kill
god but christianity lives forever you
can support new rockstars by checking
out our great merch options including
this awesome loki inspired loki out of
time shirt
get this at newrockstarsmerge.com follow
me on instagram and twitter at eavos
follow and subscribe to new rockstars
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you